[Música]
Estas son las noticias de France 24
vuelve a escalar la violencia en Israel
y los territorios palestinos en la
jornada de hoy un palestino y dos
israelíes murieron en enfrentamientos
que podrían paralizar las conversaciones
de paz que comenzaron en la vecina
Jordania
decenas de migrantes fallecieron en el
Mediterráneo cerca de las costas
italianas cuando la embarcación en la
que se transportaban para intentar
llegar a Europa náufrago el gobierno
italiano liderado por la primera
ministra Georgia meloni prometió
combatir a los traficantes de personas
y varias ciudades mexicanas fueron
escenario de manifestaciones ciudadanas
contra la reforma electoral impulsada
por el presidente Andrés Manuel López
Obrador criticada por ser considerada
como capaz de reducir la independencia y
el desempeño del INE el Instituto
Nacional electoral
muy buenas noches Bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 soy Santiago López
González Gracias por estar con nosotros
hasta ahora vamos a empezar en medio
oriente donde continúa la escalada de
violencia un ciudadano palestino asesinó
a dos israelíes en respuesta un grupo de
ciudadanos israelíes atacaron en la zona
de cisjordania en donde dejaron un
palestino muerto decenas de heridos y
varias viviendas incendiadas este hecho
podría paralizar las conversaciones de
paz entre israelíes y palestinos que
comenzaron en Jordania
es un nuevo episodio violento que vuelve
a escalar las tensiones entre israelíes
y palestinos este domingo un palestino
se acercó a un auto en una intersección
de jugara y mató a dos colonos israelíes
a balazos y la respuesta de los
israelíes no tardó en llegar quemaron
casas ocuparon residencias y dejaron Al
menos un muerto y decenas de heridos
algo por lo que hasta el Primer Ministro
de derechas Benjamín en netanyahu tuvo
que llamar a la calma
lo encontraremos lo detendremos y
ajustaremos cuentas con él pidió que
aunque la sangre hierva y los ánimos
estén calientes que no tomen la ley en
sus manos
y es que esta atención no viene de la
nada Los menos de dos meses que llevamos
de 2000 a 23 63 palestinos han sido
asesinados en las redadas casi diarias
del gobierno israelí en territorios a
palestinos el presidente de la autoridad
Palestina majuda Baz condenó lo sucedido
y señaló a Israel como responsable
el estado de Palestina condena
enérgicamente el terror racial continuo
de Israel y la guerra abierta contra el
pueblo palestino en todos los niveles
una situación que se da en paralelo a
las conversaciones de paz que comenzaron
este domingo en Jordania un tema
sensible para ambos bandos no es la
primera vez que se intentan a paralizar
con manifestaciones en contra muchos
palestinos aseguran que estas
conversaciones equivalen a ceder ante la
ocupación
esta reunión patrocinada por Estados
Unidos se celebra Mientras hay masacres
y crímenes cometidos por la ocupación
contra nuestro pueblo
ahora queda por ver si los ataques a
paralizan a los intentos de diálogo y se
retrocede al punto inicial
vamos ahora hasta Italia en donde una
embarcación que transportaba a cientos
de migrantes de diferentes
nacionalidades naufragó en aguas del mar
Mediterráneo de acuerdo con los primeros
reportes decenas de ellos fallecieron
entre ellos varios menores de edad la
primera ministra italiana Georgia meloni
lamentó este hecho también criticó a los
traficantes de personas y se comprometió
a combatirlos de otra parte Úrsula
Fender Legend la presidenta de la
comisión europea pidió acelerar la
reforma sobre migración y asilo en el
bloque comunitario
el Mediterráneo nuevamente se convirtió
en el lugar de la muerte para decenas de
migrantes luego de que una embarcación
que transportaba civiles de Afganistán
Irán Pakistán y otros países se
estrellara contra las rocas en las
costas cercanas a la localidad de
calabria dentro de las víctimas se
encontraban niños y al menos 80 personas
lograron sobrevivir La primera
administración reaccionó la tragedia y
se comprometió a lidiar con la
inmigración irregular
la primera ministra Georgia expresa su
profundo dolor por las numerosas vidas
truncadas por los traficantes de seres
humanos el gobierno se ha comprometido a
prevenir las salidas y con ellas la
ocurrencia de estas tragedias y seguirá
haciéndolo ante todo exigiendo la máxima
cooperación de los estados de salida y
de origen
la Cruz Roja italiana auxilió a los
sobrevivientes de un nuevo caso que
revive la crisis migratoria en el
Mediterráneo un asunto a tratar para la
comisión Europea
estoy profundamente entristecida por el
Terrible naufragio frente a las costas
de calabria la pérdida resultante de
Vidas de migrantes inocentes es una
tragedia todos juntos debemos redoblar
nuestros esfuerzos En el pacto sobre
migración y asilo y en el plan de acción
sobre el Mediterráneo central la
situación de los migrantes se complicó
más luego de Que el parlamento italiano
aprobara el pasado jueves un decreto que
fija un nuevo procedimiento que
condiciona la labor de los barcos de
salvamento de migrantes a pesar del
rechazo de Naciones Unidas según el
proyecto de migrantes desaparecidos de
la ONU se registraron más de 17.000
muertes y desapariciones en el
Mediterráneo central desde 2014
en Ucrania algunos ciudadanos han huido
de diferentes zonas que están cerca de
la línea del frente de batalla o que han
sido recuperadas por las tropas
ucranianas Después de varios meses de
ocupación rusa los pocos que quedan en
estas áreas del país viven en
condiciones extremas Con ausencia de
alimentos calefacción medicinas y
servicios básicos nuestros enviados
especiales Irene sabio y Héctor estepa
han recorrido algunas poblaciones
algunas de ellas completamente fantasmas
en las regiones de doniets y jarquid
este es el reporte
autos carbonizados casas destrozadas por
los misiles pintadas de la letra Z del
ejército ruso la guerra en Ucrania está
dejando decenas de pueblos arrasados
casi completamente deshabitados por la
población civil como esta aldea en el
don vass
Antón trabajaba como guardia de
seguridad en un complejo turístico del
pueblo hasta que empezó la invasión
ahora es soldado y lucha la cercana
alugangsk regresa aquí para ver lo que
queda en pie y dar comida a algunos
ancianos que no quieren irse
hemos evacuado a casi todas las personas
que conozco y ahora esto se ha dejado
así no veo razones para que algo se
reconstruya Aquí no hay nada que
reconstruir creo que se quedará de esta
manera
aquí hay casi exclusivamente militares y
el escenario es de destrucción total las
casas que vemos están calcinadas
arrasadas hay Muy pocas personas en las
calles solo pasan vehículos que
probablemente se dirigen a las
principales frentes de batalla que están
a pocos kilómetros de aquí
muchos de los pueblos fantasmas están
cerca del frente o Fueron retomados por
Ucrania después de meses de ocupación
rusa en esta aldea vivían 1300
habitantes pero la mayoría la abandonó
tras los primeros ataques tetiana es una
de las pocas personas que no se han ido
un reloj y una radio que funciona mal
marcan el paso de sus días
y es A dónde podríamos ir tenemos aquí
nuestra tierra nuestros tractores lo que
necesitamos para nuestra granja También
tenemos tres vacas que son como parte de
la familia Cómo podríamos abandonarlas
al marido Tatiana lo iría una mina y el
esposo de su amiga lo mató un misil ella
ahora sobrevive sin gas electricidad y
agua corriente y con el miedo en el
cuerpo
la realidad ucraniana en otros temas
tres buques comerciales llegaron al
puertoida el arribo es visto como una
buena señal para el comercio en un país
que está inmerso en una guerra civil
estos busquen forman parte de 18 navíos
que llegarán en los próximos días a este
país con mercancías la población local
depende en gran parte de la ayuda
humanitaria internacional debido a la
escasez de alimentos que ha llevado a
que yemen esté al borde de una hambruna
Gabriel colchón nos cuenta más
el puerto Jiménez de aludida recibió
este sábado tres buques comerciales por
primera vez desde que estalló la guerra
en 2015 el puerto controlado por los
Rebeldes atendía El 75% de las
necesidades de la población de yement
Sin embargo era inaccesible desde que
Arabia Saudita que apoya al gobierno
central con una coalición de países
impulsó un bloqueo sobre las zonas
controladas por los Rebeldes estos
buques fueron autorizados a atracar bajo
la vigilancia de la ONU
anteriormente el mecanismo de
verificación e inspección de la ONU para
yemen solo concedía autorizaciones para
determinados tipos de envíos ahora
entrega permisos para todo tipo de
envíos al puerto de aludida y si Dios
quiere esta medida facilitará la llegada
de buques En consecuencia del coste de
transporte de mercancías disminuirá
El regreso del comercio al puerto podría
ser una buena noticia para los
ya que el 80% de la población depende de
la ayuda humanitaria en las montañas del
Sur del país la única forma de
sobrevivir para parte de la población es
cortar árboles y vender la madera un
material que la gente usa para calentar
sus casas desde que el precio de la
energía subió
tengo que cortar árboles y venderlos
Para ganarme la vida no tengo ninguna
fuente de ingresos Aunque la
deforestación es un gran desastre nos
vemos obligados a hacerlo para tener
ingresos para vivir más difíciles
está atascado en una guerra civil desde
hace 8 años que deja cientos de miles de
Muertos las negociaciones entre los
Rebeldes y el gobierno central están
estancadas desde el fin de La tregua el
pasado 2 de octubre vamos ahora hasta el
continente africano en Nigeria debido a
fallas técnicas y retrasos en el conteo
de votos el horario de las elecciones
generales tuvo que ser extendido en
diferentes zonas del país entre tanto en
otras regiones de Nigeria continúa el
conteo de los votos en unos comicios
reñidos y marcados por la demora y como
les decíamos por los problemas técnicos
alrededor de 90 millones de ciudadanos
fueron a las urnas llamados para elegir
al sucesor del presidente Mohamed boady
los comicios tienen lugar en medio de un
aumento de la inseguridad y la pobreza
en ese país africano sobre los
resultados de las elecciones se
pronunció el presidente de la comisión
electoral nacional independiente
escuchemos sus palabras
hago un llamado a todos los partidos
políticos y organizaciones de medios de
comunicación para que obtengan sus
cifras solo de los resultados oficiales
publicados por la comisión como único
organismo constitucionalmente
responsable de publicar las cifras
oficiales de las elecciones
vamos ahora con temas de América Latina
en México miles de personas protestaron
en contra de la Reforma al Instituto
Nacional electoral INE una propuesta por
el presidente o hecha por el presidente
Andrés Manuel López Obrador y que fue
aprobada esta semana por el congreso
mexicano los manifestantes aseguran que
la reforma pone en riesgo la democracia
del país una versión que contrasta con
la del gobierno que asegura que la
reestructuración de este organismo es
urgente para luchar contra la supuesta
corrupción Manuela Cano nos cuenta más
la cruz una marea rosada se extendió por
el Zócalo de Ciudad de México miles de
personas se movilizaron en contra de los
cambios electorales aceptados por el
congreso mexicano el miércoles la
reforma denominada como Plan B modifica
varias leyes que promueven una reducción
presupuestal del INE el Instituto
Nacional electoral pues esta es la
marcha donde cientos de miles en todo el
país representando a millones defendemos
nuestra democracia y refrendamos
confianza en el poder judicial para
echar para atrás el plan Beck según los
manifestantes las reformas ponen en
riesgo la democracia y favorecen al
partido oficialista Morena
hacen eco de la perspectiva del INE que
asegura que los cambios estipulados
debilitarían al organismo eliminando
cerca del 85% de su personal El clamor
principal en esta marcha es defender al
INE y con ello defender la transparencia
de las elecciones la perspectiva de
Andrés Manuel López Obrador es otra el
mandatario asegura que el INE respaldó
un supuesto fraude en su contra durante
sus carreras presidenciales en 2006 y
2012 en las dos ocasiones salió como
perdedor habló ha defendido la reforma
como crucial para luchar contra su
supuesta corrupción y alegando que
ahorraría 150 millones de dólares al año
la ley ha generado controversia sobre
todo uno de sus puntos que busca
permitir la transferencia de votos entre
partidos dentro de una misma coalición
Aunque este no fue aceptado por los
congresistas la prometió impugnar la
reforma ante el tribunal supremo y se
cumplen 30 años del primer atentado
terrorista contra la torre Norte del
World Trade Center en la ciudad de Nueva
York complejo conocido en ese entonces
como las Torres Gemelas los hechos
ocurrieron el 26 de febrero de 1993 al
mediodía cuando un camión cargado con
680 kilogramos de explosivos estalló en
el estacionamiento subterráneo el
atentado dejó seis personas fallecidas y
más de mil heridos y fue reivindicado
por extremistas islámicos representó
también el primer intento de los
terroristas para derribar esta
edificación un hecho que concluyó el 11
de septiembre del 2001 cuando dos
aviones comerciales fueron impactados
contra las dos Torres provocando su
colapso y la muerte de miles de personas
y con esto llegamos al final de las
noticias en France 24 siga con nuestra
programación buenas noches
[Música]